hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to enter question from
one reader Sandra who sees I do a lot of
marketing and went to know what my role
is what my niche is and how I make my
business so Sandra thanks for the
question most of my business comes
through my website so we run an
advertising business model off the site
then I do a lot of marketing with the
videos and Facebook and YouTube and a
lot of that stuff and most of it I'm not
making any money film I do it because I
really love doing it so I love helping
entrepreneurs Manisha's entrepreneurship
I used to do a lot of this by emails
people would write in ask me questions
and I would answer them by email and try
to help as much as I could again there's
no there was no business model behind
that it's just try to be as helpful as
possible and I get my passion from from
helping entrepreneurs so I started to
turn those emails into videos so i can
help that entrepreneur do a little face
time and then also you will have other
people who might have the same problem
so it might have the same questions so
most of it is again I just do because
it's fun to like helping out
entrepreneurs some of them we do get
sponsored so we work with some bigger
brands like Telus an American Express
response of some recent videos but most
of the wines we do video almost every
day now and most of them are just out
there to help entrepreneurs is something
I really enjoy doing so I've been
fortunate to make money from the
advertising business model and it's
great to have some sponsors on board for
some of the stuff that we do with the
video content but most of it is just
because i love entrepreneurship and love
helping out you guys when i first
started my website there was no business
model behind it it was just sharing what
i was doing with my company and lessons
that i had learned and we discovered the
business model being able to sell
advertising later on and that's when my
business was able to take off but i
firmly believe in certain business
around what you're really passionate
about and a lot of entrepreneurs famous
entrepreneur successful firms to tell
you that if they didn't find a way you
know they make money with their business
they would still be doing it because
they really love it that's their passion
they would take on other jobs just to do
what they love to do and so whenever
you're starting to business I really
encourage people to start around
something they're really passionate but
really excited about things that they
would do anyway where they feel like
they can add a lot of value and as you
grow that up there'll be ways to
monetize it and you'll find ways will
make money from growing a business so
thanks for the question I hope that
helped I hope that answered answer the
question had their Sandra if you guys
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up I love making these videos for you
guys would be great to see those thumbs
up to coming in and if you have other
questions please feel free to ask in the
comments section below and stay tuned
for next episode
you